[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
what a chicken
[__] rather go to jail
[Music]
the bakery Christie
apparently Donald Trump
was trying to convince his legal team
that he would want to turn himself in
while the Republican debates were going
on good morning it's Monday morning
August 21st I am the Tony Michaels and
this is the Tony Michaels podcast as
always every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch go
to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com to find all your links
there get in the venmo chat now get it
in now so that we can get to it during
the show that's right if you give a
venmo chat we will show it during the
show so just go to the Tony michaels.com
the venmo Super Chat link is there at
the top the Tony michaels.com the link
is also down below for the venmo
oh boy oh boy oh boy
hurricane Hillary
is that rocking Southern California
Fox News is blaming it on Joe Biden
I'm not kidding you oh like you can't
make this [__] up
I guess the question is how long was it
gonna take before Fox News or someone
blamed a hurricane on Joe Biden
thanks Joe
thanks Brandon you know I used to do
those video series thanks Brandon maybe
I should bring it back for the hurricane
[Music]
I'm I'm serious
I'm dead serious
Republicans on Fox News these [__]
fascists on Fox News are trying to say
Joe Biden didn't stop Hillary
from
pounding
the Southwest
all the flooding is is clearly Joe
Biden's fault at this point I mean you
know if the guy isn't controlling
hurricanes how is he supposed to take
over the world with Hunter binds lamped
up I mean are we really expected to
believe
that Joe Biden can take over the world
with Hunter Biden's laptop but he can't
stop a hurricane come on folks
it's really wild stuff speaking of
hurricane there's a hurricane out in
California we talked to Gabe Sanchez
last night on patreon he joined my
patreon for just a minute last night to
tell us about the hurricane he had his
own patreon too uh right after mine
there's a lot of people that attended so
thank you for attending the Sunday rant
and then Gabe's Sunday q a I think he
calls it the weekend Roundup over there
on his patreon if you want to see the uh
Sunday rank go to patreon.com D Tony
Michaels or again you can go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com all the links are there
but Gabe was telling us about the the
heraquake
that is happening in Southern California
he experienced Tremors I'm sure he'll
speak about it again more today to see
how the weather is out there there's a
lot of videos coming from California and
the hurricane
Hillary
but yeah this morning Fox News is like
huh that's Joe Biden's fault
oh man must be them space lasers I don't
know what do you want from me these
people will believe anything so why
won't they say anything to them of
course they would
they would say anything that sounds
halfway uh nonsensical for them to
believe
whoosh whoosh
it's insanity and apparently Donald
Trump's legal team
on the lead story today because this is
going to continue to be the lead story
that Donald Trump
has continued continued
to figure out a way that he can skip the
debates
and the reason why is he's scared to
debate Chris Christie
that that's the only reason Donald Trump
being on stage with like Vivek ramaswamy
that guy he's gonna genuflect the Trump
no big deal
Donald Trump would destroy destroy Mike
Pence and Rhonda Santos destroy them
make them look like [__] ass [__]
like he did Jeb Bush do you remember how
he treated Jeb Bush
and Jeb Bush is like whoa what is this
kind of craziness and Jeb Bush thought
oh this is good No One's Gonna respect
this guy for treating me like this on
stage and he totally underestimated he
totally under estimated
all the Republican voters out there how
[__] how [__] vile they are
totally underestimated
total miscalculation of how vile the
Republican Party truly has become in the
last 30 years in this country
so what what do you think is going to
happen when Mike Pence and and Ron
DeSantis get the same treatment from
Donald Trump
I mean have you seen Ronda santis get
any kind of crossword from a journalist
the guy [__] short circuits
I mean absolutely short short circuits
breaks down can't [__]
stop doing the bobble head he'll
probably laugh weirdly As Trump is
making fun of him laugh at the jokes
Trump's throwing at him
Mike Pence will just probably go sit in
mother's lap
during the debate so it's not about
those two the the one person that that
Donald Trump is terrified of in this
debate is Chris Christie terrified of
him because Chris Christie ain't gonna
give a [__]
ain't gonna give two [__] about Donald
Trump and his little and his little
jokes and Chris Christie will punch back
and that's the whole reason why we need
as much as much as we we shouldn't need
Chris Christie we need Chris Christie in
this primary because he's the only one
punching at Trump he's the only one
dividing up the crowd
uh it's clear that Vivek is a plant
that's right vivec you're a plant you're
a trump plant you're not a real
candidate you're not you're there to
genuflect to him
you're there to be his number two save
event is my number two just wait just
wait the polls I'm telling you the
closer we get to Iowa the more Trump's
going to talk about the Vivek is the
only one that can beat me he's the only
one he's the only one that can beat me
you just hide and watch
hide and watch
but Chris Christie is is the fear that
Donald Trump has he's terrified he would
rather go to jail
think about that think about that he's
so scared of Chris Christie he's like oh
my God what am I gonna do what am I
gonna do
ah I'm gonna have to debate Chris
Christie or I'm gonna have to look
scared that I debate Chris Christie
because that's truly what Chris
Christie's gonna do here
Chris Christie every single thing that
comes out of Chris Christie's mouth
during the debate Chris Christie is
gonna say he's not here because he's
scared of me he's not scared of Rhonda
Santas he's not scared of [__] Mike
Pence he's scared of me and that's what
Chris Christie should do to be quite
honest and and really we need we need
Chris Christie in this primary
and the reason why we need Chris
Christie in this primary is because when
Trump does win the nomination which he
will
we need to have footage of Chris
Christie beating the ever-loving [__]
out of the Republican candidate
talk some sense into people out there to
either not go vote that's right I'm
telling you if they're gonna go vote for
Trump I'd rather them not vote [__] them
[__] them
get him to not go vote or go use their
[__] head and vote for a person who's
gonna put their shoes on and be a
president not a [__] fascist dictator
who's trying to save his own ass from
federal indictments in federal prison
because that's what Trump is doing
and he's deploying his cult on all of us
to do it
[__] him
so any weapon we can use in Chris
Christie boy you're my guy we're gonna
use you as a tool dummy
a lot of people don't oh man don't
encourage Chris [__] that encourage
Chris Christie get him in there Dr drive
those wedges down into the Republican
Party deep real [__] deep [__] him
and if Chris Christie gets on stage and
makes a a and Chris Chris have your
campaign manager call me
hey can you get Chris Christie's
campaign manager on the phone I'll let
him know what he's supposed to say
during the bait over and over and over
again Chris what you want to do is make
it all about how Donald Trump is
terrified to debate you that's what you
got to do that's how you got to do it
and oh man that that will that will
definitely definitely Drive the witch
a hundred percent uh some people on
Discord are saying that they they might
vote third party listen a vote for third
party
listen to me when I tell you this
a vote for a third party
against Trump
is a vote against Trump I know it
doesn't feel like it I know I know it
doesn't feel like it in the moment
but I'm telling you these wedges are
where we need to draw
we need we have we have to pile votes
against this [__]
and piling votes against him is super
important it's super important to pile
votes against him so if we can get a
trump vote to turn into a third party
vote
so be it because that third party vote
does not get an electoral vote in those
States Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan
Arizona
very important
we have to we have to we have to engage
in our democracy to to get turned out to
be the largest turnout of all time
in a general election this time now
right now and we have to work now from
now until next November not this
November next one 2024.
we have to work our asses off to get
that turnout
and we have to convince Republicans
voters
that their best interest is either in a
real President Joe Biden or not voting
at all
because you definitely do not want them
to vote for Trump because they will
they will
vote for Trump based on affiliation if
we do not do something and draw those
wedges deep down inside the Republican
party and Chris Christie is just the
tool to do that
oh man you're just the tool Chris and
trust me when we're done with You Chris
when we're done with you oh we're gonna
throw you out with the Republican
garbage that's for damn sure just like
we should every last [__] one of them
who was with Trump that's right I said
it oh but they weren't with Trump when
when this happened oh they were only
with him for some time and then they
turned on him I don't give a [__] if you
were with Trump in 2016 you're with
Trump now even if you're against him
we'll use you as a tool but we're gonna
get rid of fascism baby
and one of the goals is to show not just
this country but this world that we're
sick of your [__] [__]
trumpism that's the [__] we're sick of
we're sick of trumpism we're just
[__] sick of it this morning on Fox
News blaming Joe Biden listen how the
[__] can you take any allegation against
Joe Biden on Fox News seriously when
this morning they're blaming Joe Biden
for the hurricane
in Southern California are you [__]
kidding me
this is what you're gonna and you're
gonna take these people seriously
against allegations against Joe Biden
when when they're blaming the hurricane
because Joe Biden wouldn't stop the
hurricane what the [__] are you talking
about
give me a break
this is the nonsense that we have to
deal with
now apparently the scheme for Donald
Trump to turn himself into the Georgia
jail
um while the debates going on because
that's that's what he's trying to do
right here's what he's trying to do he's
gonna he's gonna turn himself in the
exact moment
that the debate happens that way he can
suck up all the media's oxygen because
he knows he knows when he turns himself
in he's gonna be able to make a show at
it because the media is a bunch of dumb
[__] they truly are I I don't know what
to tell you I know you sometimes you
hate me for saying [__] about the media
and that sort of thing or people on the
media or analysts or whatever I know you
don't like when I speak against them but
I don't give a [__] because I they
should be spoke against
this [__] media frenzy to do 24 7
coverage of him being arrested is really
stupid
it's really stupid watching his plane
showing his plane take off and then
showing his motorcade to go [__] get
arrested again
but that's his plan that's his plan
because the media is easily predictable
they're total they're total their Total
Tool in his fascist [__] regime plan
because they're boneheads they don't
understand what the [__] is going on
they don't understand they don't get it
they don't see what they're doing by
propping him up
but they'll do it they'll do it just
like they've always done it
they will what do you want from me
I mean again I don't get to make this
[__] up
I just get to tell you what the hell is
going on
and why you should be [__] pissed
about it
and how you could do something to engage
in your democracy because democracy is
the answer to the end of all this it
truly is now it's not going to be
tomorrow it's not going to be next
election or election after that it's
going to take a lot more than just a
couple years in our democracy to repair
the damage that Trump and trumpism has
done to it
and it truly has I don't know if you
heard this this morning but the Supreme
Court oh boy the Supreme it's almost
like when you elect a fascist
[__] and he gets to pick three
three Supreme Court Justices that
there's [__] consequences to all of
us
it's and it's almost like there's real
world consequences of that [__] too like
I don't know taking away Women's Health
Care and their right to health care and
their [__] privacy to Health Care
maybe like that
maybe the fact that the Supreme Court
now is deciding that they're going to
absolutely handicap Regulatory Agencies
oh yeah us the people we the people who
want to set policy and want to elect
people to government who want to
seriously govern govern to protect the
American people from I don't know greed
[__] corporations and greedy [__]
rich people the one percent because
that's what it is folks regulatory
agencies are there to protect us and our
resources from the rich I don't know if
you know that or not that's our way of
protecting our [__] from the [__]
rich
do you know that
you know the word of the government
right you know how Republic Works a
democratic constitutional republic you
know how it works right
it's us the masses the people who vote
for our Representatives who go set
policy and law who direct Regulatory
Agencies on what the [__] they're going
to regulate and why they should regulate
them and why it's so important to
protect us from their [__] greedy ass
pockets
and then tax the [__] out of them is
what we should do
yet
we we don't understand the consequences
of an election when you elect a buffoon
like Donald Trump not only does he want
to destroy democracy he wants to hand
over our country and our resources to
the one percent
that's what it's about
look they're not conservatives [__] that
[__] they don't even go look up the
goddamn word conservative go look it the
[__] up and any person who claims to be
a conservative but wants to give our
natural resources our forests our our
[__] oil
our Commodities over to rich people just
be by deregulating the industry so they
can rape and pillage us
and our country and our nation our
wealth our wealth as a nation
they're not conservative they're not
conserving anything
they're [__] fascist
that's what they are and they believe
that the one percent will handle what is
ours better than us because they're
smarter and more Superior
no it is us that gets to decide how to
advance Society not a handful of [__]
wealthy [__]
It Is Us
it's our nation it's our Republic it's
our democracy
and and when you have a consequence when
you have a consequence
of [__] standing back and letting
some [__]
take over our [__] country as a
president United States pretending to be
a leader of a Nation when he's when he
wasn't
and it takes and it takes three Supreme
Court seats this is the consequences of
our actions that's right our actions Us
in the Democracy this is what you get
when you don't engage this is what you
get when you don't take politics
seriously when you sit back and you go
you know I don't give a [__] who wins as
long as my football game's on [__]
Sunday
well excuse the [__] out of me
there's a hell of a lot more things that
are more important and if you want your
football game on Saturdays and Sundays
maybe you should pay the [__] attention
hmm just a little bit just a little bit
so when I say people who who are uh
gonna vote for Donald Trump in affiliate
style oh he's the Republican I gotta
vote for the Republican
don't get mad at me when I tell you that
we need to use Chris Christie as a wedge
to drive it down into the Republican
party so they self-suppress their food
[__] them
they aren't voting for you and me
they're voting for the rich to take away
our Republic to take away our democracy
Jesus Christ they are going to try
they're going to nominate this Whitey
little victim this whiny little [__]
pussy-ass [__] as their Presidential
nominee because somehow he's gained some
incumbency Factor that's one thing that
pisses me off about the media too
I'm sorry I'm going off on tangents here
but [__] it it's Monday it's my rant
it's the first 30 minutes I get to say
what I want the media keeps missing it
trying to tell them this morning someone
sent me a screenshot of Morning Joe I
didn't listen to Morning Joe this
morning I'm getting tired of listening
to Morning Joe if you want to know the
honest truth because they say [__] that
I said six months ago and they're just
getting and they're just now getting to
the to the to the [__] heart of it
when they could have just been listening
six months ago and they wouldn't even
had to do a show just play my show in
the morning on MSNBC hell that would
probably be [__] better anyways
but this morning they had a segment on
is it a cult is is it a cult
is it is that a [__] rhetorical
question Jesus Christ yes it's a [__]
cult it has been for 40 years
Joe Scarborough knows it's a cult he was
a member of the cult as a congressman
get the [__] out of here
Joe Scarborough I'm sure I bet you go
back and you look at Joe Scarborough's
record on the floor of the house when he
spoke I guarantee you he said Ronald
Reagan's name doesn't dozens of times
dozens he's invoked Ronald Reagan
after Ronald Reagan was President and no
longer could be president he invoked
Ronald Reagan's name Garen goddamn that
[__] still invokes Ronald
Reagan's name folks it's a cult it has
been for a long time they just never had
a desperate cult leader they always
wanted Reagan to be their desperate cult
leader but he was long gone past the
time of the really of the iron striking
hot with the cult
and then Barack Obama got elected and
they thought oh we'll make the tea party
thing we'll get that the Tea Party
Movement that racist ass movement we'll
get that going you know what I mean oh
yeah we'll get that going
and then finally finally they're
desperate feckless
buffoon
have a cult leader emerges in Trump
and it's finally it's fine it's finally
official
that the Republican party is a cult but
it's been a cult for a long time
but it really pisses me off when the
media
ah they don't see it they're talking
about Iowa polls this morning and I like
Steve kornacki Steve kornacki's a great
guy but he's missing it they run face
first into it and they don't see it
they're like well Iowa you know Trump
lost Iowa in 2016 right to Ted Cruz
and historically people in Iowa aren't
they who win Iowa aren't the aren't the
Presidential nominee blah blah blah blah
yeah well
there wasn't a Republican primary in
2020.
Trump took Iowa why why can't they see
that why Trump's going to take Iowa why
can't they see it
why can't they see it
that they're flabbergasted of why
Trump's 30 points ahead and the
assumption is he's going to take it he
is going to take Iowa
he's gonna take Iowa how is it so hard
to see the incumbency Factor Why do you
think the entire party still acts like
this guy's president to some degree
incumbency
and we've never had this in our history
before we're a [__] bona fide loser
decides he's gonna lose and lose again
and then lose some more and keep running
and it's not something we've had in our
two-party system in modern history we
just haven't had it
it's not a thing that we went through
because most the time when someone loses
they lose gracefully and they go away
they go away and they decide that the
democracy and the Republic has made the
decision to move on past them
because a president really only gets two
terms so why would they fight for a
second again
especially after being president this is
this would be like George H.W bush
running
in 1996 against Bill Clinton because he
[__] he was such a salty [__]
but he wasn't
because he knew what it meant for our
country he was an actual halfway Patriot
now don't get me wrong George H.W bush
is no [__] Saint and to our democracy
remember that cult I was talking about
and one reason why you George H.W bush
had a little bit of a problem is because
he wasn't to Ronald Reagan
it's one of the issues that he had he
tried he tried really hard to be though
oh man he tried hard oh man he tried
hard and then his son tried really hard
I had to steal an election in 2000 with
the Supreme Court
had had to had to act like
a a a veteran
like John Kerry wasn't his service
wasn't adequate enough
even though George Bush's service wasn't
near as adequate as John Gary's they had
to dress him down as not a patriot
because John Kerry spoke against the war
that he valiantly served in
um you see what I'm saying
but they miss it every time they're
missing what's going on there's an
incumbency Factor here
for Trump and it's a cult on top of it
so you think he's gonna you think he's
gonna lose Iowa you're out of your
[__] mind if you think he's gonna
lose Iowa you're out of your mind
you're out of your [__] mind the guy
has spent 45 seconds in Iowa
and it's going to win it he's probably
only going to spend maybe another 45
seconds more that's all he's going to
have to invest in it because it's a cult
and a lot of those cult members think
he's the actual president or they
actually think he legitimately lost
which is not true at all not at all
period there was no election fraud no
one stole it from me you're just a
[__] loser
but they believe he won
they believe it
and that's where the incumbency comes in
so be careful who you listen to I guess
I don't know
you can listen to me every single
weekday Monday through Friday June
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube hit the [__] subscribe
button right now what are you doing hit
it hit the Subscribe hey hey don't go
anywhere hit the Subscribe button it's
free and give me a thumbs up if you like
what I'm saying if you don't find give
me a thumbs down get in the comments
tell me why I'm wrong let's do that
if you want to do a venmo chat send me
send me a venmo chat you go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com or you use the QR code
right there on the screen
and get in the venmo chat the
tonymichaels.com also uh the Discord is
popping over there today it's where the
chat party never stops if you want to
join the Discord it's a hell of a way to
engage with the [__] fan it really is
this is incredible it's almost like the
YouTube chat here the [__] fam jet 24
7 over there on Discord I'm gonna put
the link in the chat right now so you
have it that way you can go join the
Discord today
uh stick around we'll be right back get
your Discord figured out while we're at
break we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
I have no idea what happened there
oh no I don't know I thought I was gonna
jump in I guess it uh it cut me
oh boy we're gonna get Gabe Sanchez on
here in just a little bit uh let's see
what's the first thing we're gonna do
here well he says he's going to be here
in about 15 minutes so clock him and you
guys clock him when he's going to be
here
let's see what are we what do we got
this morning I want to show you this uh
this uh this clip of Fox News it's not
very long I'm blaming Joe Biden this is
[__] some wild [__] folks this is
some wild stuff here it is here's Fox
News uh talking about how how they're
going to blame it on Joe Biden let's
listen the big story tonight
[Music]
the wrath of tropical storm Hillary 42
million desperate souls in the path of
the storm which made landfall in Mexico
several hours ago but they let it right
into the country because it's Biden's
America
they let it right oh my God
they let it right into the country as
Biden's America can you believe that
I didn't believe it oh my God
what the [__] are you talking about are
you serious are you serious
well let's listen
over this is the first tropical storm to
hit
Senate career
oh my God you can't make this [__] up
you cannot make this [__] up I guarantee
you go into comments today it's gonna be
the reason why the reason why the
hurricane is in Southern California is
because Joe Biden didn't continue to
make Trump's wall that's what it is oh
the wall would have kept it out maybe a
Sharpie maybe that's the problem that's
the problem is Joe Biden isn't using the
presidential Sharpie the way he should
that's probably what it is how I mean
what do I know what do I know about this
stuff are you [__] kidding me are you
[__] serious
this is their weather breakdown I'm not
kidding they said this [__] look I'm
gonna show it to you again watch watch
watch if if it'll play of course it's
not going to play
I'm having all kinds of technical
difficulties that's how it goes
when you're live on on on air you know
what I mean do it live do it live all
right here let's try it again let's try
it again here's here's here's Fox News
with their great weather report and I'm
serious it says Fox Weather they do
weather like they do news
and they should be called Fox weather
like they should be called Fox News not
at all listen the big story
the Wrath tropical storm Hillary 42
million desperate souls in the path of
the storm which made landfall in Mexico
several hours ago but they let it right
into the country because it's Biden's
America it's impact far from over this
is the first tropical storm to hit
California since
1939.
oh my God you can't make it up it's so
funny I can't I can't even I can't even
tell you how [__] ridiculous this is
they let it into the country and that's
the other thing flatlander makes a good
point here Souls Souls
are they are they counting all the
Liberals in Southern California are they
leaving those Souls out
how are they how are they doing the
numbers here
because you know what I'm telling you
there's there's Republicans that are
super excited oh man they're [__]
excited that this this hurricane is hit
land ball I mean Ted Cruz
Ted Cruz has even fallen for this [__]
watch look at this look at this here's
Ted Cruz he says holy crap to this tweet
right here you see the picture of the
shark are you [__] kidding me again
this this is a this photo originated
appeared in 2011 after Hurricane Irene
hit Puerto Rico The hoax also made the
rounds in 2015 after Texas was hit with
heavy rains and 2016 during Hurricane
Matthew so this isn't the first time
it's been used as a hoax in the state of
Texas it's been used as a hoax and Ted
Cruz says holy crap
these people are just not serious people
you know you know what I've been saying
lately I say it's not you know
no offense to lawyers or attorneys out
there but it can't be that hard to be an
attorney it can't be I mean to be a good
attorney and a great attorney it's
probably really difficult takes a lot of
work to be one of the best attorneys and
a good attorney but to just be an
attorney is it really that hard
and Ted Cruz is one
Ted Cruz is one man
come on
what do you what do you want from me I'm
just going off of evidence this is just
evidence that I'm using that's out in
the open public don't come at me
you're saying it can't be that hard to
actually just be
a lawyer and it's really not that hard
to you know imagine that United States
senators are [__] full of [__]
but again
Ted Cruz Falls for a hoax
because you know
I don't know maybe maybe he he has a
soft spot for sharks because he loves
Cancun that much I have no idea are
there many sharks in Cancun though I
don't know
who knows
well Ted Cruz definitely doesn't know
that
I want to play you a report here from
Scott McFarland
speaking of attorneys oh I've talked a
lot about Judge shetkin and what she is
and isn't going to do in this case uh a
lot of people are like oh she should
jail him for his front Social account he
broke the law
okay he intimidated a witness in Georgia
right I get it but
she's probably not gonna do that
she's probably not
probably not gonna do that
and you know what this week it doesn't
look like she's gonna do that
don't know guys she's gonna do it
I you know I'm telling you
but um here this report from Scott
McFarland uh really lays out judge
chetkin and not only her her her history
as a judge but on their prosecutorial uh
history but it lays out her record on
January 6 which I think is important and
listen to what he says about sentencing
that's the most important thing listen
Chuck in was it a point to your former
president Obama has served in the U.S
District Court for D.C and is handled
dozens of these January six prosecutions
I've sat in her courtroom for many of
the sentencing hearings the plea
agreement hearings listen to what she's
had to say about these cases she's been
a distinctive voice
unequivocally a distinctive voice she
has been particularly vocal with her
concerns about what happened here
January 6th what gave rise to it the
implications it has on our democracy she
has said in so many words our democracy
remains in Peril kind of speaks to the
to the point Joseph made earlier that we
seem to be a country divided judge
chutkin has noted that outwardly at
hearings he's also been one of the rare
judges I've seen to exceed the
recommended sentencing levels issued by
the Department of Justice
okay so that's really important so she
exceeds this sentencing
guidelines from the Department of
Justice now what that means is is that
when you go to federal court and you
either plead guilty or you are convicted
what the pre-trial uh apparatus of the
federal courts do is figure out based on
a systematic way of scoring points
that's literally how they figure it out
they score points based on your history
and your charges and all that kind of
stuff there's all sorts of things that
play into the sentencing guideline and
the the court
comes the pre-trial
officer comes up with a report that's
hey here's here's what the guidelines
say here's how the guidelines judge
these are based on the federal
guidelines and then the prosecutors give
what they want they're like ah the
guidelines say 18 years but we really
want 25. or you know Mark Meadows
cooperated with us fully
during our federal investigation so we
want to give him a down slide in the
guidelines and we recommend a year and a
day as opposed to five years judge
now the judge has the authority to
exceed or go below those guidelines the
judge can say [__] you I'm not
sentencing you to anything just
probation or she can say oh oh the
guidelines say five years well [__] you
she can go all the way up to the minimum
whip all the way up to it now this is
important right this is important to
think about in this context this is not
going to happen for a long time
a long time before judge Chuck can
actually hence the opportunity to
sentence Donald Trump
okay
so be clear on this when you're hearing
these things like what Scott is
reporting here is because Scott's
reporting uh very very eloquently the
news about Judge second and her history
on sentencing January 6 defendants but
remember this is the sentencing part
this is the sentencing part
she's very very fair she's very
fair-handed in a courtroom she's going
to be
this is who she is not only was she a
prosecutor but she was a public defender
so she knows the challenges in a
courtroom
for a defense and a prosecution she
knows she knows that both the defense is
afforded certain rights
and they and she will make sure Donald
Trump receives his rights I guaran
goddamn T you then that judge judkin is
not going to to to to go out on a limb
and not give Donald Trump everything
that anyone else has afforded in a
courtroom she will do it
it's gonna piss you off sometimes
probably there's gonna be certain
decisions that she's gonna make
and it's gonna seem like she's swinging
in Trump's favor
but she's swinging in the favor of his
rights as a defendant not necessarily As
Trump
because that's who judge shotkin is but
in the end in the end she is fair as
well if the jury finds them to be guilty
she will use her Authority as a judge to
lay the hammer down on you
so just give it a little bit of of time
because it's not going to happen
tomorrow it's not going to be in January
you're probably not going to see any
advancement of a trial in the spring
it's just not going to happen stop
having this fantasy that somehow
chutkins gonna jail him for what he what
he posts on true social is vile as it is
uh even David points out here on on
let's see if I can find a bank I thought
I have it there David points out what
he's calling peop black people on
on true social calling them Rickers
intentionally with an r two hard R's I
guess you could say here's David's
comment Trump is now openly called black
people riggers in this post let's see
how that goes right I I understand I
understand that that feels like she
would jail him but she's not gonna do it
she's not gonna do it
she's not
I hate I hate to be the bearer of bad
news but I just don't see judge chutkin
because he's [__] posting on true social
now as soon as he intimidates a witness
in DC you're done
I think she's gonna lay hammers down
but I I do not I do not believe that
this judge being who she is and what she
is and how she is ruled so far is going
to just jail him because he's posting on
true social
I don't see it
I don't see it but let's listen to the
rest of Scott's report here I think it's
interesting on January six defendants go
to sentencing they recommend a sentence
the prosecutors recommend a sentence and
the judge decides where to go and judge
chutkin's been one of the rare judges to
exceed the recommendations issued by the
Department of Justice not saying that
has a direct implication on how she'll
handle Donald Trump's case but it's not
worthy to what degree then there's the
Trump team saying that because of the
things she has said or what you're
talking about could impact whether the
president gets a fair shake or not yeah
I posted some of the words shutkin has
used in court and Donald Trump's team or
Donald Trump himself reiterated my
reporting on his truth social platform
disseminating some of what judge chutkin
has said he's been making the argument
the judge should recuse or the case
should be moved there's a concern I
suspect from the Trump legal team about
that trial percentage I mentioned
earlier 100 of the juries who've handled
January six cases have at least
partially convicted the defendant
and that is important uh you heard that
a hundred percent of every case that's
gone to a jury trial in DC
about the January 6 case has has 100
percent
resulted in some of the charges being
found guilty and the reason why the
reason why is because it is what it is
these people were recording themselves
they were bragging about it on social
media they were talking to each other in
different uh platforms and channels
about what their plans were this wasn't
hard to figure out they just had to
gather up the evidence and convict them
that's it indict them bring them to
court convict them and the jury found
them guilty a hundred percent of the
time of some of the charges that were
brought to him no one's walked out of
that Courthouse
being exonerated of all charges Donald
Trump will not either
and I promise you judge chutkin will get
to a trial at some point be patient she
will get there she is not going to let
this not go to trial I guaran goddamn
tea it
but judge jetkin is going to be fair
and she's going to be stoic
and in the end in the end judge chetkin
will do the right thing because she is
the right judge in the right moment in
this right piece of History
as wild as this timeline is she's the
one who can handle this case better than
anyone
so trust her trust her judgment trust
her judge ship trust her experience
and trust her love of democracy and and
knowing what Justice is and what Justice
isn't
and understand when this decisions come
from DC because I'm telling you the
Georgia case is going to be the circus
right that's the circus that's going to
be the circus and the reason why is
because Georgia law allows it to be a
circus
with the cameras and all the footage and
all the coverage
it's gonna be a [__] show down in
Georgia and it's becoming more and more
clear with more and more defendants in
this thing depending on who who actually
uh flips and who turns State evidence
down in Georgia how long it's going to
take but it is going to be an absolute
[__] show to get to a trial down in
Georgia
I believe that chetkin will not allow
her courtroom
and will not allow this case to be
become a [__] show
the federal laws allow for her to do
that and I believe she will do that
so just stay fast let's listen to the
rest of the scouts report I think it's
important here the jury pool in
Washington D.C may be politically
demographically quite different than
other jury pools and other Federal
jurisdictions and we've heard Trump's
legal team talk about the fanciful idea
of moving the case to the Northern
District of West Virginia or elsewhere
in the nation those motions to change
venue have not succeeded not one has
succeeded in January 6 case no
indication this would work
so there there is a Scots final report
on um on C-Span so go go check out uh
Scott you definitely want to follow us
got on social media platforms now he's
done impeccable reporting on the January
6th uh
on the January 6th defendants and their
cases
um I want to show you guys we had a uh
um a thing last week ad Fontes media do
you remember this we put up a graphic
last week and gave
because Gabe's about to come on I think
Gabe was a little he doesn't like this
graphic he doesn't like how Aunt Ed
Fontes does this but I want to show you
they actually have a Facebook page and
they're posting this all over Facebook
at Fontes is
um they they do this media bias chart
every so often and they compile this
information
um and and they use us as one of their
sources and of course I like our
placement most people don't I think it's
correct especially when you consider all
the other [__] that they have on
this thing when Joe Rogan and and
Russell Brand and Barstool Sports is in
the middle
hey hey
okay yeah okay so considering that I I
consider my placement to be correct
um but but um I actually said oh they
have a Facebook page so if you're on
Facebook right now I just want to point
out that um Ann Fuentes has a Facebook
page uh maybe we'll talk a little more
about that when Gabe comes on I know he
wants to talk about
um how Donald Trump's uh website was
hacked so we'll talk about that too
but there's a great video out or a great
video I found on online it's on it was
on Tick Tock I guess someone posted on
Twitter this is a speaking of people who
have destroyed our democracy Donald
Trump but this shows you uh in an
interesting way how he really has
destroyed our democracy watch last night
I congratulated Donald Trump and offered
to work with him on behalf of our
country I have just called President
Obama to congratulate him on his victory
I had the honor of calling Senator
Barack Obama to congratulate him
please
I spoke to President Bush and I offered
him and Laura our congratulations on
their Victory now the U.S Supreme Court
has spoken while I strongly disagree
with the Court's decision I accept it
the president was my opponent not my
enemy and I wish him well and I pledge
my support and America must always come
first so we will get behind this new
president and wish him wish him well
this nation faces major challenges ahead
and we must work together he has won
we are all Americans
he is our president in bringing about an
ordinary transition of government in the
weeks ahead I congratulate you on your
victory
congratulations on your victory
we've got a president-elect he's going
to have my help
cheers
I have no bitterness no Rancor at all he
will have my wholehearted support
the people have rendered their verdict
and I gladly accepted I urge all
Americans to unite behind you
and every good American will
wholeheartedly accept the will of the
people I accept the result of the
election with complete Goodwill
[Music]
this is an embarrassment to our country
we were getting ready to win this
election
frankly we did win this election
[Applause]
so there's that video and it shows it in
an interesting way
um not only in a video form but with the
little kid sitting and watching the TV
and learning about our democracy and
what it is and what it isn't and again
that we've never had in our history in
our modern history a president or
presidential candidate who wasn't
graceful
enough to lose with some [__] dignity
and he has none he has no dignity he has
no shame this is why in 2016 when
Hillary Clinton was warning us about
Donald Trump becoming the president
United States that it would it would
damage our democracy possibly topple it
she wasn't [__] kidding
and this is the reason why
this is the reason why and this is the
threat I think this ad is better than
almost any I've ever seen
as far as the danger of trump
and the danger isn't Trump himself it
really isn't Trump is a [__] symptom
of this disease and it's fascism
fascism is the disease that has led to
Trump
and to com to be complacent and have
cognitive dissonance towards fascism has
led to Trump he is just the [__]
symptom he is not the disease
and we must rid ourselves of the disease
and that is why it is so important for
us to use our strategic outrage to
engage in our democracy and Advance our
Republic
as that democracy
so that is why we must every single day
work hard for our nation
and yes it feels like well what can I do
you can do a lot
you can do a hell a lot we've been doing
a lot of uh 10 minute uh workshops 10
minute tips on
on Roundtable of democracy you can join
us on patreon let's go to patreon.com D
Tony Michaels there's a lot of stuff you
can do to engage we're going to do a few
this week
we're going to do another follow-up on
field team six if you want to do
postcards uh maybe we'll do another one
on fivecalls.org and we also have ballot
pedia coming we're going to do one on
ballotpedia so stay tuned to Round Table
of democracy just go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can find the patreon
links and the Roundtable democracy
playlist right there on the page
speaking of finding something and
finding someone
we finally have my co-host uh let's see
let's make sure he's not underwater Gabe
Sanchez how are you faring with the
storm out there uh good the storm has uh
has passed oh really okay yeah as far as
I know the storm maybe maybe the thing
is that Trump's wall stopped it
um you know I I thought about that you
know that's a possibility yeah I've
heard a lot of reasons yeah right for
what why the storm came into uh into the
West Coast you know into the country I'm
gonna come I'm Gonna Come
yeah
uh oh I'm gonna come
uh yeah no it's uh you know luckily I
don't live on the first floor so I
didn't have to deal with anything in
terms of that I was actually just
walking I was just walking my dog who I
was like come on you take a [__] [__]
man come on let's go were they nervous
were they nervous yeah yesterday uh my
little one of my little dogs uh she's
not a big fan of the rain and so like
while she would go out and go pee like I
was like oh the whole day she didn't go
take a [__] so like okay like there's no
rain anymore let's let's get this right
let's get it over with yeah right have
you ever but you've been nervous taking
a [__] before yeah I mean whenever
whenever I'm out and just the you know
out in public and I'm like so when you
get it what do you get do you when you
get in a public restroom do you get a
little anxious
oh so you just go and Let it Loose yeah
I'm white or anything yeah it's like
just let her rip right you're in a band
you're in a public bathroom and somebody
farts and it's like
or someone take this [__] it's like
that's the whole purpose of the thing
right that's well that's where you're
supposed to do it yeah I mean I mean if
you were in the middle of the grocery
store and there was someone you know in
the cereal aisle that would be a little
weird yeah it would be a little weird
three for sure but but if you're in the
bathroom of the grocery store that's an
appropriate place to do it yeah yeah so
did the dog so the dog ended up taking a
[__] then yeah yeah okay but I was
walking around and some actually it's uh
so like
I live in an apartment building so I
didn't have this I didn't have the same
type of damage that some people other
people had right I've seen some trees
down I've seen like
um
I've seen different utility trucks go
around to like clean up so did you guys
lose power did you guys lose power no we
actually didn't lose power but they're
going I think they're going through and
they're like doing second checks on
everything I mean I saw there was some
private uh Crews that were like pumping
water out of so some apartment buildings
in a like a couple blocks nearby
they've got like this downward
they've got they've got a uh a down like
a like a parking area under right right
and that's slow some of it's flooded or
yeah because you know they only have
like a small little grate to filter out
water and right it's like a storm drain
not a not a hurricane exactly right and
so as a result it was just kind of
flooded so I saw this morning like Joe
Biden thanks Joe
and so they they were bringing down a
huge like almost like
um like a fire hydrant hose to like pump
out all the water so I've seen some
areas that got more damage I saw a truck
this morning that uh part of This
Woman's driveway is like like gravel or
like uh dirt and it just the rain had
completely just created this
like everything was washed away so part
of her driveway was gone so her truck
like slid into the house oh wow well uh
blue dot Dusty on Facebook says why are
we talking farts and [__] look sometimes
you just have to get these subjects out
of the way you know you just gotta get
them sometimes you talk about topic one
and then you gotta move on to topic
number two right and then and then you
just gotta [__] or get off the pot and
we that's what we said we did both
okay so speaking of [__]
uh Kid Rock
Kid Rock apparently likes butt light
again dude super woke super woke you
know what I I said this over the weekend
I tweeted it he never stopped drinking
Bud Light yeah that's all but you never
stopped drinking it he never stops
selling it the boy has been a fan of
man I break it all down in my what was
that dude it's just the the absurdity of
people have you seen the one thing I did
not include in this is the conspiracy
and I covered it last night during the
weekend Roundup but the absurdity that
some people have where they're like
this is such a [__] fake I've had
people that came in
wait wait stop you're saying that the
right wing is like oh this is all this
is all fake yeah let me let me I'll find
the Tweet so here's here's here's the
thing
um this is at a concert in Nashville so
I'm gonna give you the context this is a
concert in Nashville now when you go to
concerts they don't just serve one beer
okay you got choices so not only is Kid
Rock drinking a beer but he had a choice
between other beers and here's how I
know that he bought it at a concession
stand at the event is because it's in a
can it's in a can they would not
probably serve bottles at you know
sporting or concerts events and the
reason why is because glass bottles end
up becoming weapons or can become
weapons an aluminum can I mean I guess
you could cut some [__] with
aluminum can you know it might be a
little more difficult but you can cut
someone up with aluminum can but it's
not really like an instant weapon I mean
unless it's full like that one guy found
out of a t of a hard a hard tea uh in
the gas station a year ago yeah the the
Twisted Tea yeah the Twisted Tea I feel
like Chris I I feel like there's so many
moments of Twisted Tea being used as a
like a as a weapon as a weapon to like
kick down bigotry right you know well
ain't that about a [__]
um so here's now this is uh this is the
the one claiming that oh it's fake is
that this one yeah I mean somebody
somebody wrote in the comments
um last night they're like I think this
person's drunk
this is the account it says I saw TMZ
put out a story showing Kid Rock
drinking Bud Light actually he was
drinking Coors Light can yeah there's no
punctuation
yeah uh look at the pic carefully also
the blue outline does not match the blue
cans someone took oh Jesus Christ is
it's more meganomics uh-huh
so okay so what's the what's the thing
that they're doing here is that they're
basically trying to say that the logo on
the can isn't really a Bud Light can
it's a Coors Light can and they're
covering it up now this is not the and I
didn't even get the I did not even
mention this like throwaway kind of
moment I did make a comment in the what
was there I'll send you the link but uh
the one thing I do mention there is like
oh I can imagine what they're gonna say
is that they're gonna tell me that it's
not Kid Rock I didn't even think to
address the can Tony I I thought in my
mind I was like oh they're gonna go
after Kid Rock that's they're gonna be
like they're gonna be like this some guy
who looks like him well no they can't
see they can't go after Kid Rock the
reason why they can't go after Kid Rock
here is because Kid Rock was the one who
showed him this right Kid Rock is the
one because before this I mean yeah
Dylan people were bitching like trolls
were bitching you know these closeted
trolls who like to troll uh trans women
and and because they have an obsession
with them yeah and so they troll these
trans women right online no one did you
know who Dylan Mulvaney was before this
nope I had no idea I honestly had no
idea who she was I had I I'm not
that well I mean like obviously it's not
my it's not my you know my target
audience and as well as you know it's
it's also because because she does like
makeup and styling and this and that and
it's like that's just not something that
shows up in my algorithm right you don't
watch makeup videos so you're probably
not gonna but I I say I think Maga for
educating me on right exactly you know
but but the thing is is that these
[__] weirdos
are out there you know trying to troll
uh Dylan mulvania and others like her
um with hate and they saw the Bud Light
thing and they started freaking out and
it was low level freak out until Kid
Rock set up the beer cans and shot him
up right yep no one no one paid
attention and it it [__] went viral
so then they were all doing it but they
were all still drinking Bud Light they
were all still drinking Bud Light folks
and even if they weren't drinking Bud
Light they were drinking the same as Bud
Light and a different can Bush light and
make a low vulture I've seen this [__]
when I go to events like concerts and
people are like oh you're gonna drink
Bud Light and I'm like what are you
drinking they're like Michelob Ultra I'm
like you realize that's the same [__]
beer you dumbass
it's the same beer it's the same [__]
dummy it's in a different can what do
you what the [__] are you talking about
but that's just how they are they're not
they're not they're not thinking with
their brain cells the three that they
got left yeah they're not so is this the
is this the uh what was that yeah this
is the what was that that breaks this
whole thing down okay well let's let's
go ahead since we're on this topic let's
go ahead and play the um what was that
here uh from from Gabe about this
situation that we have uh with Kid Rock
if I can get I I really need to get an
ad blocker get the [__] ad blocker
man I I know I know I've got one right
here dude it's very easy it's just
called ad block
oh
we'll look into it okay can you guys can
you guys look into an ad blocker yeah
usually you should you should have them
do their own research okay I'll tell the
team to research and figure out
right just get them them to do the ad
blocker here is the newest what was that
kid rock exposed as woke queer beer Bud
Light Drinker what was that by Gabe's
inches welcome to what was that I'm Gabe
Sanchez Republicans have spent months
attacking and trying to cancel Bud Light
as if it was their Civil War but as
suspected it's all been fake outrage
especially from Kid Rock but before we
get into that make sure to like this
video subscribe to this Channel and ring
that notification Bell so you never miss
another episode so let's just back up a
moment I feel like I need to set the
stage for how this Republican tantrum
even started it was all because of Bud
light's sponsorship of an April 1st
Instagram post with trans Tick Tock star
Dylan Mulvaney hi impressive varying
skills right I got some Bud Lights for
us
so I kept hearing about this thing
called March Madness and I thought we
were all just having a hectic month but
it turns out it has something to do with
sports and I'm not sure exactly which
sport but either way it's a cause to
celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers the party that calls other people
snowflakes got so in their feelings over
a can with a trans woman's face on it
that they decided to boycott it this
beer sucks
dang really
they go down the drain
of course
would be my choice
hey Budweiser I've been drinking your
beer for probably 35 plus years
not anymore
y'all screwed up well jokes on these
transphobic idiots because Budweiser has
been partnered with glad for two decades
and those who are switching over to
Coors that company has been committed to
the lgbtq plus Community since 1978.
really shows you how much Republicans
actually know about beer but hey don't
let facts get in the way of their cancel
culture now some Republicans were so
pissed off that they decided the only
way to stop that gay trans beer from
ever touching another American Patriot's
lips was to destroy it
foreign
ticket to Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory
[Music]
not to mention there are a few problems
with his bizarre and aggressive strategy
while it is under the same company those
were cases of bush light not Bud Light
also that can of Bud Light with Dylan's
face on it from her video was a
promotional novelty can which means only
one ever existed and lastly when you
round you're gonna find out here he is
getting walked out of the Walmart in
handcuffs by the police so just to
summarize a beer company put a trans
woman in a marketing campaign and things
immediately escalated to the point where
Republicans lost their [__] minds and
it wasn't just in stores other
Republicans went out to buy case of Bud
Light in order to destroy them which
makes absolutely no sense but then again
Republicans have never been great at
critical thinking free tip for
Republicans if you're boycotting a
product you're not supposed to buy said
products the company has your money so
it doesn't care what you do with it and
the person to do just that was Kid Rock
in early April he bought several cases
of Bud Light just to take them home so
he could shoot them with an AR-15 man
what a time to be alive Grandpa I was
feeling a little frisky today
let me uh say something to all you and B
as clear and concise as possible
wait hold on a sec did you all notice
that shooting pattern in the video
someone is shooting another high-powered
rifle off screen from the right which
means there are at least three people
trying to own the leaves right now Kid
Rock a second shooter in the person
filming but let's see if Kid Rock has
anything more to say Bud Light it
[__] Anheuser-Busch have a terrific
day
I don't know about you but big bad Kid
Rock shooting cans of watery beer and
giving Anheuser-Busch and Bud Light the
middle finger is very scary and very
intimidating so after this video came
out Kid Rock became the poster child for
transphobicate and trying to cancel Bud
Light it was like they were saying wwkrd
what would Kid Rock do I mean
wwrjrd what would Robert James Richie do
well Robert certainly wouldn't lie to
everyone and turn out to be a hypocrite
no I'm not talking about Robert actually
growing up in an upper middle class
family on a wealthy estate 40 miles
outside of Detroit nope I'm not talking
about him drinking Bud Light and parting
with drag queens that was so 2003. it's
2023 and Kid Rock is a full-on raging
transphobe and no I'm not talking about
April 8th at the UFC fight when Kid Rock
decided that he was on team Coors again
a company that has been pro-lgbtq plus
since 1978. I'm actually talking about
him attending Colt Ford's show at the
sky deck on Broadway in Nashville and
drinking an ice cold can of Bud Light I
can just see Matt a crime right now
yo I don't have a panic attack
and I know exactly what Republicans are
going to say to this that's not Kid Rock
that's some guy who looks like Kid Rock
well not so fast because when you know
it I have a video posted from the sky
deck on Broadway's Instagram account
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
from the way we are greeted to the
quality of the food
[__] hands man what do you want for
me to do
Kid Rock on the balcony with a Bud Light
in his hand this feels like I just
solved a game of Clue you know what
actually I'm just going to give him the
benefit of the doubt and assume that he
never looked at the can everyone makes
mistakes what he sells Bud Light at his
restaurant in Nashville we'll see for
ourselves let's take a look at Kid
Rock's big ass honky Tonkin rock and
roll Steakhouse geez that's a mouthful
according to his menu they serve a
variety of Premium beers such as Corona
Heineken and PBR wait PBR is a premium
beer anyway he also serves domestic
beers such as Budweiser Bud Light Bud
Light Lime and Busch Light wait what the
Kid Rock explicitly said Bud Light and
[__] Anheuser-Busch there must be
some mistake like a typo or maybe the
menu is just out of date they were
selling Bud Light during pride month
this year and there are photos why am I
not surprised there are always receipts
proving the Republican party's hypocrisy
in cancel culture and even when
Anheuser-Busch trying to remedy the
situation with a half-assed apology and
then later abandoned Dylan Republicans
still weren't happy they even threatened
Dylan's life to the point where she
didn't feel safe leaving her own home
Republicans are so committed to their
hateful anti-christian bigoted cancel
culture that they don't even care if
Americans lose their jobs because of it
they're actually happy about it I mean
what kind of sick anti-American [__] is
that like Lauren bobert celebrating
Anheuser-Busch having to lay off roughly
350 employees due to the Republican
party's boycotts or like how Ron
DeSantis wants to sue the company
because Florida's pension is so heavily
invested in it we do have these shares
we believe that when you take your eye
off the ball like that you're not
following your fiduciary duty to do the
best you can for your shareholders so
we're going to be launching an inquiry
about Bud Light and inbev and it could
be something that leads to a derivative
lawsuit filed on behalf of the
shareholders of the Florida pension fund
because at the end of the day there's
got to be penalties for when you put
business aside to focus on your social
agenda at the expense of hard-working
people the guy literally called for
Republicans to boycott woke Bud Light
and now he's whining that their boycott
is negatively impacting his constituents
pensions in this idiot wants to be
president or even Ted Cruz saying back
in May that he wanted to investigate Bud
Light for the marketing partnership with
Dylan Mulvaney to investigate what Bud
Light was doing with Dylan Mulvaney it
destroyed a brand that may not recover
what's your focus
well listen I I can't think of a company
in modern times that has more alienated
its customer base and and seem to have
so little understanding of who it is
that actually drinks Bud Light but but
this week I sent a letter to the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch along with Senator Marsha
Blackburn because the CEO of
Anheuser-Busch is also the CEO or the
chairman of the beer Institute which is
the regulatory body the industry
regulatory body that regulates itself
and one of the rules that beer companies
are supposed to follow is they're not
supposed to Market to kids remember the
whole whole Joe the camel thing this is
the same thing here well you know what
Dylan Mulvaney a massive percentage of
Dylan Mulvaney's audience our kids and
Budweiser was trying I believe with this
ill-fated marketing attempt to Target
teenagers if you look at things Dylan
Mulvaney has online it's things like
days of girlhood there's another video
where Dylan Mulvaney is singing my name
is Eloise and I am six there's another
one where Dylan Mulvaney is shopping for
Barbie dolls these are clearly things
aimed at teenagers and even children
younger than teenagers which violates
the rules and so we're calling on the
beer Institute to investigate the degree
to which Anheuser-Busch knowingly was
marketing to children in going down this
road look Ted I'm not sure if you're
aware but the world is facing some
pretty significant challenges right now
we've got climate change income
inequality Global conflicts a broken
power grid in Texas and you're out here
fighting the good fight against beer
leave it to Ted Cruz to weaponize the
government to go after a beer company
that sent a single can to Dylan Mulvaney
for an Instagram post not to mention
neither party was advertising to kids
and now three months later Ted Cruz has
sent a letter to Anheuser-Busch urging
them to cooperate with his Senate
investigation into Bud Light but let's
be honest the only reason that Ted Cruz
wants a hearing is to show that he's
working Cruz is up for re-election and
his Democratic Challenger representative
Colin Allred has recently outraised him
8.8 million to 3.4 Million by bottom
line Ted Cruz is scared and he's trying
anything he can to stay relevant just
like every other Republican clamoring to
weaponize the government to cancel Bud
Light
well that's all from me today thanks so
much for watching and feel free to
connect with me at I am Gabe Sanchez and
if you feel like supporting me as an
independent Creator make sure to check
out my patreon as a member you'll get
access to episodes before they release a
bonus show on the weekends discounted
merch and live q and A's to subscribe go
to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez oh what
was that what was that with Gabe Sanchez
that was a great one you know the
commercial wasn't bad either in there
yeah you know it is what it is it's
pretty good but yeah that's what I do
man I went I dude I went I went [__]
sleuth and I was going through
everything I was reading about all you
know most of it most of it I did know
and I actually had a Budweiser uh video
planned and then
you know things the whole Kid Rock thing
yeah yeah and so I was like oh great
okay I can I can you know reuse and
recycle some of the stuff that I had not
posted yet so well there is one thing
that you missed in this whole Saga oh no
other than the fact that they blamed on
the can which you see in the video that
you show where where he's standing there
like the baddest [__] of all
time the fake ass rapper whose parents
paid for him to be an Entertainer and
that's why we all know who Kid Rock is
Kid Rock and he's standing on the
mountain he takes his head up and he's
holding he's holding a blue can which is
a bud line can not a Coors can so he
actually chose I would like to see what
the list of drinks that were that were
in the concession in at that show I like
to see the list of drinks what he had to
choose from yeah and why he chose the
butter it's probably pretty similar to
what he offers it's got to be all of the
same National beers on top of you know
most of the same premium beers I would
say like Bud Light there was probably
Ultra there was probably coolers there
was probably like uh yinglings or
something Yingling is really popular
right now which is the which is the
which I want to say is the beer that all
of the right wing people Republicans are
saying don't drink Bud drink Yingling
made in America where's where's
Yuengling where's Yingling from I think
it's like is it on the East Coast yeah
look it up look it up I want to show you
what you missed in this whole Sanga of
right Wingers
um from Boston Smalls here he says
what's going on with Maga lately alpha
male Kid Rock spotted drinking queer
beer and alpha male Ted nugen apparently
with an arsenal of dildos have you seen
this picture no so here's here's the Kid
Rock one is that a real photo here's the
Kid Rock I mean that's a real photo but
the other one here here is here is uh
here's Ted Nugent apparently Ted
Nugent's doing his podcast with dildos I
don't know I you know uh Pottsville
Pennsylvania there are two Factor there
are two uh breweries in Pottsville
Pennsylvania and one in town Tampa
Florida oh my God so it's a
historic Hospital breweries open for
tours in the Tampa Campus is scheduled
to open in 2022 so that was and so
that's Yingling that's the one that's
the one that everyone on the right was
like hey don't drink Bud Light you gotta
go to Yingling that's something here's
the thing about Yingling is that um um
it's been becoming popular for a while
and you know the reason why it's been
becoming popular for a while it tastes
like uh what's that one beer that's
really popular in America and has been
for like the last 40 years it's been the
number one beer tastes a lot like it
what one is it yeah I think that's it
yeah that's what it is but here is again
I just want to point this out this is
Ted Nugent on whatever thing I don't
know what this is some kind of internet
show he looks like [__] by the way well
that's what happens when you're uh I
mean can we call him a child rapist well
I mean that's what he is right well I
mean as an adult he was was it 14 well
he's got a lot of hate in his heart too
you know you know
will do that but it's if she was 14
right like that's the type of person
that Ted Nugent is right but he's got as
many dildos as he's got guns I'm just
gonna go out on a also are those like
those like little badges you get when
you like donate to a local police
department and they're like here's a bad
so you can show Cops that you're a fan
and hope that when you get pulled over
you don't get a ticket do you think you
got to bring your dildos too when you do
that probably I don't know he brings him
in cuffs and he's like take me officer
take me take me in take me in I'm gonna
come I really want I'm gonna come I
really need to um I really need to what
I need to do is is get that on a video
here we need to put that as a sound
button yeah so we can so we can put the
you know get it where we go
um speaking of um Kid Rock and content
here is a tennis and um Tennessee Brando
with his latest song You're gonna like
it it's about this kid rock Saga so
we're going to continue this for just a
few minutes let's listen the Tennessee
Brando's new new ditty about it all
right well I wrote the song Kid Rock
won't drink Bud Light anymore and turns
out he still does so here's the sequel
Kid Rocks drinking Bud Light again
I guess it's little temper tantrum it
was all pretends
just making
his cash in in
[Music]
Kid Rocks drinking Bud Light again
a coattail rider for first day one
I had some Fool's thinking he was Hank's
Rebel Son
beating scary Old Times wrapping old
cliches
[Music]
waving a flag we had done thrown away
then he grabbed his rifle and he threw a
little fit like any other seven really
gave a flying [__] he was feeling kind
of frisky acting pretty pissed he sure
ain't Country cause he's still [__]
missed
now Kid Rock's drinking the light again
at this point he's just spawning it in
just a full-blown manga hypocrite
yeah Kid Rock's drinking Bud Light again
[Music]
oh man oh man Tennessee Miranda let me
tell you I love I love me some Tennessee
Brands he's got some nice and he coming
he comes he comes quick with him you
know yeah I know it's it's a gift man I
I wish I could look one I wish I could
uh play the guitar and the second is I
wish I could come up with songs as
quickly as he does yeah I know he's he's
brilliant at it what do you got here in
the chat here for me
so since we're on the topic this is
actually brought up but we might we
might as we might as well keep going you
know how easy it is to dunk on Kid Rock
yeah
so this is in the same in the same tone
of right wing oh this is this is
consequences of their bigotry yes
exactly what this is yeah I heard the
story this morning and it pissed me off
a little bit I planned on talking about
it today so I'm glad we brought it up in
this context to show you how this
nonsense this this fake outrage over Bud
Light causes people to lose their lives
that's right innocent people this is an
innocent story innocent you know people
who are become victims and this woman is
66 year old Laura Ann Carlton and she
was the the shop owner and she had you
know again
her business
what she wants to do with it is her
right just like all of these Republicans
who say oh I don't want to have to make
a [__] cake for a gay wedding or I
don't have to make a website for a gay
wedding do you know how many businesses
I've drove past in my part of the
country where there's a trump flag
hanging out front I mean it makes it
really easy to decide not to go
patronize that business yeah but it's
their right to to put their whatever
flag they want out front you you own the
business you pay your taxes that is your
property and you can decide what you
want to do with it all right and here is
and here is uh uh Laura and uh
Charleston again she's a mother of I
believe nine
um and she was killed on Friday for
displaying a pride flag outside her
sword in Southern California she was
shot and killed hmm I wonder I wonder
what it could be about the right Wingers
thinking they could take a gun and kill
someone now uh apparently Laura Ann was
not a member of the lgbtq community she
was just a Ally as a tax on the lgbtq
Community rights have increased from the
right wing media and Michael Republicans
still have hate crimes Laura should
still be here she should not be a victim
of gun violence and a hate crime and and
the hate crime that she is guilty of is
being an ally
that she's being an ally there was no
evidence it wasn't like she made any
sort of like inflammatory remarks or
statements or anything like that in
support of the lgbtq plus Community all
she did was she put a flag outside
and the person who did make inflammatory
comments was the man who shot her
are they reporting exactly what he said
they'd uh from what I saw just like
several disparaging remarks about a
rainbow flag that stood outside
Carlton's store before ultimately
shooting her so it sounds like he made
the cut he made the comments
and then shot her I just want to point
out too earlier in the year the FBI
released a supplemental 2021 hate crime
statistics reporting its highest levels
to date uh victims targeted because they
were lgbtq or the members of the gay
community increased by 70 percent I
wonder what it could be
I wonder what weird it's almost it's
almost like there was an increase in
crime under Trump's presidency
especially in areas in which it would
have rallies
and then now you see these things where
there's been an increase against an
already marginalized community and
Republicans are the ones who want to say
oh we're the real victims we're the real
victims we're getting we're are getting
this indoctrination forced into our face
into our schools in our places you're
in our places
no no they the the people who hate are
putting it in your face for you to hate
as well and and it again I've said it
time and time again and I'll say it over
and over and over again the Nazis or you
may not think you're Nazis but the Nazis
the actual Nazis they think you're Nazis
and they're the ones who are trying to
perpetuate this stuff and get you uh in
the trouble that you're getting in
um
speaking of weird ass [__] and and just
fake ass stuff I want to show you this
again and I I want to point this [__]
scumbag out here
because this is more fake ass outrageous
DC Drano oh my God this [__] guy okay
so he posted a video of Joe Biden at
Beau Biden's feet you know what Beau
Biden is yeah
who's Beau Biden can you give me a
refresher of who Beau Biden is Joe
Biden's son okay and he died of cancer
okay he died huh he died wow so this is
Joe Biden at Beau Biden's funeral this
little kid here in the front is Bo's son
at Joe Biden's grandson and his dad's
funeral and Joe Biden is standing there
consoling him at his dad's funeral now
DC Drano decides to post this video
again and say never forget how this man
treats children when he thinks no
cameras are watching you mean you mean
like you mean like comforting his
grandson you [__] pile of trash
here's what I said I said you will
always be known for this type of dirty
trick propaganda keep digging you
[__] low life DC Drano is a [__]
low life he's a [__] fascist he's a
goddamn Nazi I said it Rogaine you're a
[__] Nazi and this type of [__] is
Despicable and vile I don't I don't come
here and talk about Joe Biden a lot I
don't come here and hail his
accomplishments every [__] day
because I gotta fight [__] like
DC Drano here my efforts are to fight
this [__] here who is spreading
false goddamn propaganda on the internet
to get right Wingers all riled up
and this goes into the whole lgbtq
Community [__] too because they believe
that every single gay person is a
pedophile and a predator and groomer and
all that [__] and they also think
that every Democrat that's a creditor
and that's where they try to make this
connection that it's all it's always
Democratic that's right the cabal
they're trying to come after kids we're
trying to save them not Democrats even
though Republicans are the ones who are
saying [__] your kids literally they're
trying to [__] your kids that's what
Republicans are trying to do they're
trying to marry 12 year olds they're
trying to say it's okay to have sex them
they're trying to say oh they these
children should have uh their own babies
when they're raped or when when there's
incest but these children don't have the
same intelligence or maturity to have an
abortion
this is the Republican party and I'm not
I'm not I'm not even speaking hyperbole
I'm literally saying what Republicans
have decided for several children that
have been brought up recently in
different news in different articles or
in cases where they said children that
are as young as 12 who have 13 or 14 who
have gotten pregnant are not mature
enough for to have the decision of
making uh of deciding to have an
abortion however they are mature and
intelligent enough to have the baby
themselves
here is here's the community notes of
course it was Community noted it said
this video was taken out of context this
video and it's not taken out of context
that's [__] it's not taken out of
context he is he's a [__] scumbag
you're a [__] scumbag Nazi you're a
line sack of [__] [__] and and by the
way an avid Trump supporter I wonder if
there could be a connection there this
video was taken out of context this
video is from June 2016 at the funeral
of Joe Biden's son Beau after he passed
away from brain cancer that then Vice
President Biden has seen embracing
beau's son Hunter
whose father was being laid to rest you
[__] scumbag piece of [__] trash
listen when I tell you that these
[__] are not Christian they're
not [__] Patriots they're they're
very [__] Un-American can you imagine
can you imagine can you [__] imagine
using a video of Donald Trump consoling
his grandson because his son had died
and at the funeral I ca I looked and I
hate that [__] I hate that
[__] with the passion that's
right hate is the proper word and that
[__] can't leave this earth fast
enough but the one thing I would not do
is use a video of him consoling his
grandson at his son's funeral as some
sort of propaganda that Joe Biden likes
to diddle kids it really is projection
DC Drano it really [__] is and I'm
calling on maybe authorities I don't
know maybe there could be authorities
that could go check rogaine's [__]
[__] goddamn electronic devices if he
thinks this video is out of turn I
wonder what else that [__] has
stored on his electronic devices I mean
you better I mean you look at them all I
mean every other person like uh like
Margaret Taylor green
Matt Gates Lauren bobert
[__] anyone everything
Rick Scott Ted Cruz don't do the John
Kennedy right now but what I will say is
like all of the people in the Republican
party like you said it's complete
projection
what they do is they they yell and they
scream as loud as they can and they say
we're the victims we gotta save the
children we gotta do this we gotta do
that and then you find out that nine
times if not ten times out of ten
the very people who were yelling and
screaming about Democrats being
pedophiles and some crazy Democratic
cabal or according to Marjorie Taylor
green cable
it turns out that the very people who
are doing that are the ones who were
guilty of it
the people who know best are gonna say
those things
well the thing is like I like to hang
out with each other and I said it last
night I was like there's a reason that
Donald Trump a rapist hung out with
Jeffrey Epstein
birds of a feather you hang out and you
are around people that reflect the same
things as you you are The Company You
Keep and Republicans
oh boy man that's a [__] messed up
company well I I'm telling you this type
of dirty trick propaganda DC Drano was
going down in history is a [__]
scumbag and no one will ever respect
anything that [__] has ever said
or ever done no matter how legitimate it
may be because this D gentle D
legitimizes everything about him and
remember that you [__] scumbag
remember when I told you Rogaine
remember when I told you in that Twitter
space I told you your [__] stupid ass
delusion is going to be Trump's demise
remember I [__] said that you
[__] remember that I said that
and that's directed directly at you DC
Drano you piece of [__] trash
um speaking of trash what's this other
video you got for me here okay this is
dude Nick sorter he's the guy that
always shut up on these Mario spaces
he's like yeah sometimes sometimes he's
like the sometimes he's the co-host yeah
like he's trying to run the show
especially especially on the hunter
Biden stuff yeah he loves him he loves
to talk about Hunter Biden's [__] no
I'll tell you this even the people who
run Mario space is literally told me and
they said Nick's order he's not great at
doing these we're actually looking for
someone else really they told you that
so you have a DM to prove that no I have
a voice I have I have I don't have a DM
I have a phone call that I have
with a certain person I can't say who
they are oh I see you can't can't
divulge The Source
related to these spaces and they said
Nick sorter is not good at co-hosting
and they're and he's like and we're also
looking for new co-hosts
um Carrie says I love that Tony calls
these [__] that will be
prepared I'm sure I'm gonna call this
[__] out I haven't watched this
clip I know this is amazing it is
amazing because Nick sorter if anyone
doesn't know who Nick's order is he they
don't they don't they don't know
Nick's disorder is this like
investigative journalist I'm a I'm a
citizen journalist meaning meaning
meaning he's not a journalist that's
what that means it's just like you don't
have to put a descriptor before it
you're a journalist okay fine or you're
an analyst or you are you're not but the
whole like differentiation of saying
like Oh I'm a citizen or I'm uh and you
know it's just like no you if you're
gonna be a journalist be a journalist
don't put a thing on the front of it
like you're trying to be special or like
you're different or like you're more
important or like you're oh I'm straight
to the source I know exactly what the
mainstream media doesn't know no you're
if you want to be a journalist you're a
journalist that's what it is Nick sorter
though the way that he works is he'll
fly or go to different locations and
then try to exploit the situation so
that he can you know Cloud Chase and he
did it at east uh East Palestine
in Ohio in Ohio at the train wreckage
exactly there's a video of him throwing
a rock into the river and there was like
some uh chemicals and do the same thing
no JD Vance didn't go there what he did
is he he hung out with a rifle trying to
shoot down the Chinese air balloon oh
yeah but I thought he stood in the
actually yeah he did he he went back and
now he's got it you know the whole third
eye up here so what he did was so what
he did was is he copied Nick's order
here that's [__] pathetic that's
[__] pathetic and that's not even the
first time that oh man Nick sorter has
done this he's done it in other
occasions too but Nick sorters his MO is
he will show up to a disaster or some
situation and then exploit it for his
own gain so he'll go on Tucker Carlson
Steve Bannon uh Jesse watt all the other
all these other shows and this one in
particular is him on Steve Bannon show
and he's in Hawaii after the fires oh
he's he's there too report on what's
going on I'm sure this happens I'm sure
this can't be disgusting at all let's
take a listen
yes it is yes uh that was one of the
questions that uh it's like I said it's
been burning in a lot of people's minds
here
hey what's up Nick I've been trying to
reach you've been reaching not to on x
um
this whole thing is
okay yeah so this is this is so you're
seeing this live right now people
actually track they track me down
I'm not taking up any resources here yes
you are
yeah
Steven is like oh baby this is this is
like dude there's a couple times where
he's like don't don't go away don't
leave right do not pull away we're
staying on this right and the reason why
the reason why is because Steve Bandit
doesn't care if he destroys Nick oh yeah
he's like this is good this is good
media touch right this is a good TV
right here right look at Nick here man I
I really is he's supposed to be an alpha
ma'am
if you look at if you look at Nick's
eyes I'm almost I'm almost curious and
other people can can uh confirm with me
in the chat when you see him kind of
looks like Nick's orders beginning to
cry just watch for it all we just watch
it all play out
you stupid Devastation you've seen the
people
see you cheering up because you know how
much these people are suffering no
you're you're you're literally
here you just
okay
what what Nick what what's the ear to do
here we go victimhood in three two one
it's so awkward look at Steve Manny's
like oh I can't wait to destroy this
rule
this is real dude this is what I I'm
getting I'm getting chases there we go
there we go
now see see this this is what happened I
ended up getting dots no you didn't I
mean these
I
um
it's one dude asking him questions
I didn't post a picture of myself
your location the palm trees the water
they doxed me you posted I'm sorry Steve
I'm just I'm
forward right now Steve's not sorry at
all Steve's like keep going I can't wait
to destroy this [__] we're gonna
make a whole thing out of this how we
destroyed Nick shorter the investigative
journalist here I mean because Steve
look at Steve Bannon he's he's he is in
his special place here honestly you know
what you know what I'm with you Steve
[__] Nick [__] this guy [__] Nick hey
Nick if you're listening because I I
know I know Nick Mayer may not listen to
the show because I hear his voice like
when I heard his voice in uh and it's
totally different from what you expect
right well I it it feels it feels like
he would have a molestash and he
certainly does have one and he really
has that 1980s creeper look I'm not
gonna lie Nick dude you need to you need
what I suggest Nick is go lift lift a
few weights Tan Your Balls a little bit
go find a barber that can do a decent
[__] haircut that thing looks like
[__] okay it looks like [__] and then
find to Barbara that can give you a good
guidance on facial hair too okay do that
you you just don't look alpha male
enough and that's probably why Steve
Bannon is feeding you to the [__]
wolves here let's keep watching and see
if anything turns up on this yeah
I don't know
I don't know 15 feet away
so
um well I mean listen the the guy that's
following him is using assault questions
you know what I mean they're not like
normal questions or hunting questions
like that you would use you know just in
average everyday life These are assault
questions these things are really
dangerous these questions that this guy
is asking why are you taking up
resources here on the island these
questions are very you know they're
hurtful to Nick's feelings yeah and
they're hurtful to the truth they really
they really aren't they really are
um but let's let's continue here let's
see if anything happens to Nick here
this part gets good
yeah I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna try to quickly get away
no I'm sorry I
I don't even know what to say to be
honest this is terrifying oh God this is
terrifying it's terrifying as it goes
further into the woods instead of going
into the parking lot where it's lit if
he's so scared about his life oh my God
I don't even want to go near my vehicle
I don't I don't want them to know what
vehicle I'm driving either
Nick's order
um gets cucked by some guy asking him a
few questions about why he's taking
resource that's fantastic Nick this is
this is great this is great content um
frankly uh and if you'd like to come on
the show for me to make fun of you in
front of your face for it I would love
for that to happen too so but just reach
out it wasn't the footage wasn't
doctored you didn't see any anything
special came in the guy literally said
hey Nick you said you were going to be
here on he didn't call it Twitter he
called it X right so he's already
adopted you would think this this guy's
a blue check Ally yeah but he said hey I
saw you that you were going to be here
on X and then called him out and he said
you're exploiting you're taking
resources and it was like unintegrated
resources goes yeah you are you being
here right now is taking away from
what's Happening because obviously
Nick's reporting is going to be very
skewed in how or what is presented
and as we watched
Nick was like oh the guy just asking
questions you know he's like 50 he's
like five feet away and then 10 feet and
then he's like 15 feet away at different
points
and next I was like ah I'm so scared as
he walks into a darker area when you're
like oh man I really hope nobody [__]
mugs me here oh this guy this guy's
looking at me and asking questions he's
following me yeah go for it's like Nick
never watched a horror movie and he was
like oh you know where I should go I
should go down into the basement
well you know who else's Kryptonite is
just uh reasonable questions you know
this is Kryptonite is reasonable
questions this guy and and you know he's
kind of like Nick here are we at the Wax
Museum it's really weird
um watching this guy his facial
expressions in the very beginning when
they're asking questions it's almost
like the uh the santis AI doesn't
process questions as well as the new
technology this I I really think the
DeSantis um campaign should not consider
new staff maybe you should consider the
upgrade uh AI That's what you should do
for the fascist authoritarian Android
Rhonda Sanders but let's watch how he
gets totally melts down about a question
this is this is great this is great
footage for the end of Ron desantis's
career your campaign said uh the other
day that the knives are out for you at
that debate I gotta ask you about that
plus I gotta ask you I know it's not
your campaign but never back down put
out a memo that people are talking about
so I'd like to get your reaction to both
well on the memo it's not mine I haven't
read it um and it's just I think it's
something that we we have in the uh put
off to the side but in terms of debate
look when you're I know from the
military when you're over the target
that's when you're taking Flack and if
you look really in the last six to nine
months I've been more attacked than
anybody else Biden Harris the media
other Republican candidates and there's
a reason for that because people know
there's a guy following me in the
parking lot asking me questions because
I posted on X and and I'm running for
president and my political opponents are
saying bad stuff about me it's really
bad it's really bad and I can't dig it
you [__] bunch of goddamn [__] you
bunch of [__] [__] on the right I
am so sick of people telling me that kid
rock Rhonda santis and people like Nick
sorter are [__] masculine and manly
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense
nonsense these people are [__] whiny
little [__] they're the whiniest
they're the whiniest little [__]
[__] I've ever seen in my [__]
life Rhonda santis didn't think he was
gonna get attacked by his political
opponents by entering the president to
race what are you [__] dumb you
people I can't even believe anyone would
support this [__] and I'm happy
I am happy I am happy Ron that you
entered this race the way you entered it
and how you entered and how your [__]
political career is gonna end I am so
[__] excited to never have to [__]
hear the name Rhonda Santos without
laughing my [__] head off ever again
it's gonna be great you're gonna be a
footnote in [__] history that you
[__] destroyed Florida and not only
to destroy Florida but you [__] got
your political career hammered by Trump
and Chris Christie good [__] you [__]
so I gotta say about that hold on I
gotta I got a quick story about uh this
is a this is a
all right here we go this is before
and then this is after so you want me to
show you the before first I want you to
show me the four okay this is because we
brought up X earlier this is in this is
in relation to twitter.com okay so this
is James Woods he's tweeting here James
Woods that's right he's tweeting about
the block button okay the block feature
that Elon Musk that Elon Musk said they
wanted to get rid of right we talked
about this last week but it really
doesn't seem like a possibility because
he'll be kicked off the the App Store
you have to have the ability to block on
user generated content social media
sites that is a requirement of both the
Apple store and then also the Google
Play let me ask you if he takes the
black if he takes the black feature away
do you think they'll take him down off
the store they could because it's
breaking the guidelines unless he finds
some alternative way to say like well
but didn't they give him didn't they
give him leeway for the guidelines of
having two characters as the name
they did so I'm just I'm just pointing
that out but the problem the problem
with that is that's a name not the
Safety and Security I understand on an
app I understand I'm just going based on
the facts I get it I get it that they
are willing to bend the rules for the
richest man well
formerly known as the fakest richest man
in the world but here's James Woods here
he says thank you if Elon Musk removes
the ability to block
concerted harassment by trolls concert
and harassment by trolls or organized
political entities how will quote X I
love him
as if it's not really X yeah be any
different from Jack dorsey's horrid
Twitter
musk whom I once championed is only
doing this to protect his advertisers
anyways
users of hex are mere pawns to turn the
site into an electronic shopping mall
that was his plan along dummy why were
you supporting him then the man I
thought was a defender of free speech is
just another greedy capitalist
disappointing but not surprising James
Wood you're against capitalism you know
you'd make it you make a great scroll
down now scroll down to this one no no
no no no no no go down go down it should
be a reply
ah hold on let me see if I can find it
it should be Elon responding oh Elon
responded to him Elon responded ah yeah
yeah okay here we go here's the
don't click that second link just yet
click this last one I sent you so this
is this is elon's response to the tweet
I just read of of James Wood
um because he didn't know that Elon was
a catalyst
um
I don't know I'm in agreeance with Elon
once yeah for once me and Elon can agree
on something delete your [__] account
delete it right yeah delete delete your
[__] account [__] okay no I just
want I just wanna I just wanna set this
up here
this is all because of the block feature
that Elon Musk wants to take away and
James Wood says no no you got to keep
the block feature because then I'm gonna
have [__] controls in here
then fast forward to this moment
and here's uh James Woods pointing out
which is exactly my point have a nice
day
Elon Musk blocked him yeah
oh my God you can't make how in the [__]
did we get in a situation where
three-year-olds are running huge
apparatuses of social media in this
country I have no idea man we have you
know the dumbest the dumbest people make
themselves appear as if they're the
smartest people oh my God and Elon Musk
is another person who by the way is
notorious for blocking people he blocks
reporters journalists anyone who's
trying to question his you know ulterior
motive he will always will always block
them oh oh don't don't get it twisted
Elon Musk is definitely going to keep
the black feature open for himself yeah
well I mean yeah well you know features
for me not for thee that's what they say
right right well here's his account and
he doesn't have me blocked I need to
change that probably but look look at
this this account is so [__] fake you
can't convince me as a hundred and fifty
three you want to know how fast you want
to know how fake and he has a hundred
only 119 subscriptions come on Tony I
don't know if you come on if you read
this over the weekend yeah
here we go here we go so Matt binder or
man I think is or Matt Bender actually I
think it's Matt Bender he works for a
few different Publications online but he
wrote an article for Mashable this
weekend
and he broke down what we have known to
be true but he went further into it
and he he started actually figuring out
the numbers for Elon musk's 153 million
followers on Twitter right
and went through and found out that
there's a certain Trend with these
followers oh so it's concerning oh this
concerning interesting so the question
is are they fake or are they a bot or
what is it right so what is it what do
they discover here so I don't know how
to read this whole thing yeah yeah
let me let me get I'll give you the
tweet that actually has uh okay that's
great yeah let's do a tweet it'd be
better to find it because he breaks down
the numbers and basically says like this
is what's going on with these followers
and that they're not
anywhere close to what is being claimed
right now but this isn't surprising
almost always not at all these right
wing I mean that's that's been always
the conspiracy theory about Mario's uh
Twitter spaces is that half of them are
aren't real people listening to the
Twitter space it's all bot Farms that
they raid the the um the actual space
with to have to have conversations I
haven't been in Mario's rooms for a long
time because they always survive they
reached out to me the other day and then
they canceled the space and it's like
all right whatever yeah there was a
couple I was going to talk in but they
always frame the space up really stupid
like is Hunter Biden's [__] really 10
inches we'll find out tonight in Mario's
space I'm serious tonight at 6 p.m
Pacific we'll find out exactly how long
that's long I'm I'm telling you so
they're gonna they want to invite me to
a debate of how big Hunter's dick is and
I'm like look I'm really not interested
in Hunter's [__] I'm really not I mean
as much as you guys are I'm not okay I'm
just okay that's your prerogative right
it's what I mean you do you boo but uh
you know I if I want to see you know
that kind of stuff I'll just go search
it I don't need to talk on a Twitter
space about it
like Lee Kelly says
Hunter's hog strikes again but that's
literally kind of how they frame these
things up is
um you know and they'll frame them up
against Biden and [__] it's really
[__] dumb and it seems like Nick is
the one who comes up with the title
sometimes so the ones that Nick comes up
with I'm like you know it's it's like
when I mean Nick sorter back to Nick's
order for people who uh cures he's also
the same guy who posted the photo of
Hunter Biden's lawyer smoking out of a
bong
who lives in Malibu California is it
legal there is it legal there it's not
only it's not only medicinal right it's
recreational so you're telling me that
he wasn't doing anything wrong other
than what Nick thought he was doing
wrong because they took the Daily Mail
took a photo of Hunter Biden at the home
at one point and then took a photo of
the lawyer at the sorry Hunter they took
a photo of Hunter Biden at his lawyer's
home in Malibu one point then they had a
photo of Hunter Biden's lawyer smoking a
bong at a different point now you can't
tell me
that these events happen at the same
time and even if they did I could tell
you two things one the lawyer went
outside and smoked out of the bong
totally illegal his home it's California
he can do what he wants
right well at least he went outside to
smoke the bomb and then some people said
man if I was representing Hunter Biden I
too would take [__] hits off a bong
which right you know it's funny hey you
know I I don't but either way it's nice
maybe maybe Hunter brought the [__] to
smoke I don't know and who gives a [__]
uh like Mad Max
the way that Nick presented he was like
oh here's Hunter Biden's uh his lawyer
ripping itself a bong and I'm like all
right that makes him cool I guess I
don't know what to tell you I don't know
what this bird is here hey Nick Nick
we're all getting high these days dummy
you're a [__] idiot but that is that
is great we shouldn't make a parody
in Mario and the Falls Twitter space
we're gonna find out how long Hunter
Biden schlong actually is like that's
some of the headlines that they've got
here's Matt here um back to uh speaking
of uh [__] uh here is uh his uh
numbers on Elon Musk these are the three
top bullet points of these numbers 40
greater than 42 of Elon Musk followers
have zero followers on their own account
wait wait wait you're saying you're
saying if someone's following him
42 percent of those people more than 42
has and they have no followers
themselves it feels like it feels like
that let's count to me remember how he
was gonna get rid of the Bots maybe what
he meant was is I'm gonna consolidate
all the Bots to follow my account yes
but then he also was like I'm gonna come
I'm gonna come
um set more than 72 or less have less
than 10 followers that has the stench of
troll on it too on bot troll uh over 40
of most followers have zero post on
there she says [__] Christ man
this is ridiculous I mean when you own
the farm you might as well control the
Bots right that's right right oh my God
that's [__] hilarious well you know
it's again it's not it's not abnormal
that these [__] idiots on the right
wing
um they they fake everything it's all
fraud it's fake like Nick was like yeah
I'm down here to report on the fire even
though I'm that close to it and I'm
gathering up resources or I'm taking up
resources for other people like hotel
rooms and [__] like that to broadcast to
make standard feel good and then I get
really scared when I boast on x and a
blue check from X comes up and questions
me about posting on Excel man I get my
feelings hurt it's all [__] fake man
it's not real it's not real journalism
it's all [__] it's like people it's
like Advantage saying that we're [__]
news get the hell out of here man we're
not news we're making fun of the news
until until we make that video that says
tonight at 6 00 PM we're gonna figure
out just how long Hunter schlong is
tonight at 6 p.m and Mario involved
space
we're gonna find out how long
actually is stay tuned don't touch that
dial oh my God she's [__] Christ
okay so um grandpa that's what we're
dealing with Grandpa undecided that
let's go back to the lead story let's go
all the way full circle wait are you
gonna tell me that Hunter I mean sorry
not if I see you got my mind on Hunter
body now
it's like for the girl with the hot dogs
in the face yeah like
yeah but are you yeah zero days are we
at zero days I think we're like negative
400 now good are you gonna tell me
that there's a similarity between the
way that Elon Musk and Nick Sorter and
other Republicans Act is similar to
something that I I mean like I don't
know the story yet
but are you gonna say that it's close to
what happened with Donald Trump well go
ahead and tell the story well no I mean
I'm just wondering are you talking about
the very fact that Donald Trump decided
he's not going to show up to the the
debate well of course he's not he can't
he can't because he's scared of Christy
well yes and he's a [__]
he is and you know the craziest part is
he was like went to his legal team he's
like you know what we should do because
he's really looking for any way to get
out of this bait he's like what we
should do is act like I have to get
arrested during the debate so the news
is is that I'm arrested and then they're
standing here which is not a good idea
anyways yeah right it's not a good idea
because Chris Christie's gonna beat the
[__] out of him in this debate even
though he's not going to be standing
there and he's and Chris Christie's
going to beat the [__] out of all the
candidates who won't beat the [__] out
of him
doing the best part the best part about
this
is
it's I mean I'm I'm definitely I'm going
to position this argument is Chris
Christie is going to go through and he's
gonna [__] rank the coals with these
guys right he's gonna take him out one
by one to the shed and be like all right
you're done you're done you're done
vivec you're a [__] plan for Donald
Trump you're okay with him not showing
up
that's okay again if anyone had any
doubts I literally sent uh Tony a
message last night with a screenshot the
background of Swami was like yeah I'm
totally fine with Donald Trump not
showing up to the debates the only
reason you say that is if you're trying
to position yourself in an actual
position
within his administration for later
the only reason you say that is if
you're working you're colluding the
collusion collusion collusion if you're
actually colluding with Donald Trump
when it comes to him running for
president
so Chris Christie's going to go through
and he's gonna [__] drag them all and
the best part about this is Donald Trump
can't say anything about it because he's
not going to be there to defend himself
not like he really could but even when
he goes excuse me excuse me rude rude
like even if
even if he was there that would be his
go-to where he would try to interrupt
and because he's not there he can't
interrupt which means that all of these
thoughts and statements that Chris
Christie is going to bring out and put
out there into the Lexicon The Ether
cannot be refuted by Donald Trump in
real time the closest he'll be able to
get is Avec ramaswamy talking in his ear
right well that's true and here's the
thing about the truth and the truth is
is that it's always projection with
these fools right it always it always is
projection with them and I want to show
you more evidence speaking of evidence
that Donald Trump's a fool I want to
give you evidence that there that
Republicans are obsessed with
with [__] I don't know how else to I
don't know how else to put this to you I
love some caulk not like the kind that
you uh seal your bathroom with the kind
that they would love to have you can't
you can't use caulk to steal your
bathroom yeah I don't know maybe you can
and depending on how big it is
um this was pointed out by Rachel
bidikov I think Tennessee holler had
this too or so I don't remember where
this came from it was Sergio laning
around
whoever made this Banner yeah well and
they also had a truck at this uh this
ball field that says [__] Biden on it
now it says Republican place a giant
penis billboard with President Biden's
face and Biden sucks on it at a Little
League field in Virginia this set of
little league you know they care about
the children
do they though do they though I mean
they they like to have signs that say
Biden sucks you see this here you see
um it looks like this is a phallic I'm
just trying to understand okay so yeah
Joe Biden's face is on the head his head
is the head of the day hey what listen
he's coming so he's going to come he's
coming I'm going to come I'm gonna come
I'm gonna come and he's coming on this
Trump supporter right here I guess so
she's standing there getting [__] on
but he sucks but if he's the head of his
own if he'd be sucking the dick I don't
know well no no this is saying he sucks
but somebody else is sucking his dick
and then you're like wait is this Joe
Biden's dick that's a huge dick you know
hey you know what this runs in the
family I guess this is what that's what
they're really mad about that's what
they're really mad about is because they
know Hunter Biden has a huge dick huge
massive [__] and they know that it had
to been inherited from somewhere
probably that's what they're mad about
big step in I guess it's real this is
100 real this is the reality I swear to
you this is real they had to take this
down off the bleachers and they put it
on the pickup truck that has the [__]
Biden uh flag but no someone was in
Virginia at a ball field saw this and
started taking pictures what's funny
about this this Biden sucks Banner is
it's
it's cut in half like they couldn't
print it on one sheet they're like oh
we'll get halfway there we'll get we'll
get like a half Chuck Biden and then the
other half like shaft in the balls Biden
and then the other side sucks oh also
wait what the [__] uh zoom in
uh
zoom in please
I don't know if people pointed this out
because I've seen this before but I
haven't really like looked at it much I
was like oh boy
if you zoom in on this image it won't
let me okay hold on let me get send me
the link right now and I'll I'll send
you the uh images all right all right
all right actually right click it right
click it right click it
all right send me the link I'll send you
a link and then you can I'll and then
I'll send it back to you with thing
because I wanna I wanna point something
out that I just noticed because I zoomed
in
mm-hmm
all right
we're we're we're late on time but I
thought we would give the audience a
sense of how obsessed they are with huge
Biden [__] yes and this
is how weird their obsession is I don't
know who wrote this I don't know if it
was them or someone else now click that
image and zoom in
foreign
this is ridiculous I'm sorry I just have
to point this out because it's honestly
insane all right go to the head of the
dick
I'll give her something I thought I
would say we're at the balls right now
okay we're at the boat let's leave it up
go to the shop your hands are huge yeah
look at it I mean at least they throw a
vein in there now go to the bottom right
corner
oh right there uh what does that say my
kids I guess why are they my kids I
don't know this doesn't make any sense
Biden's head is the head of the penis
and then there's
come and but the but it's actually my
kids I don't know is it his kids
is it Biden's kids I don't get who is
the who is mine I don't know but this
lady this lady is standing here she is
really wanting to get my money shot no
sense but I just wanted to point this
out because this group is so weird and
so obsessed with dick it's like dude if
you want it man just go get it just go
find it yourself it's always just be
your true self and go enjoy that be
yourself be your yourself oh my God
these [__] people have lost their
minds and we will stay on top of it I'll
show you the evidence every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern I can't believe it's been two
[__] hours already hey man when you
when you talk about
dicks and [__] ass [__] and and yeah
I mean time flies when you're making fun
of Republicans wise when you're punching
Nazis and make sure it flies here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central don't forget to
hit the Subscribe button on YouTube
right now it's 3.99 don't forget to
subscribe also if you want to send a
venmo chat send that in let's see if we
got anything today only we got in any
today where where's the venmo chats at
just go to the tonymichaels.com go to
thetonymichaels.com you can find all the
links there and
yes it's come to this uh Billy boy says
on YouTube it's come to this also don't
forget to stay in the Discord where the
chat party never stops if you want to
continue to talk to the [__] fam 24
7. go to the Discord I'm telling you you
don't want to miss out on this now they
stream stuff over there they do all
kinds of stuff I'll put the um I'll put
the link in the chat here so you can
find it really easy but you know where
you can go you know to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com to watch us on Facebook
twitch Twitter download every single
episode on Apple's Spotify and Google
all the links are there on the Tony
michaels.com
we'll be back tomorrow and I'm sure
there'll be more [__] [__] Obsession
to talk about I'm almost positive never
not be man this thing they've been
saying they've been saying uh botic and
suck my dick since since Donald Trump
lost and it's like for a group of people
that really hate gay people it's kind of
weird into certain gay phrases that you
would consider weird it's weird I mean
if you got a problem with it whatever
hey whatever that's who you are do you
do you man you do you Boo and we will do
us tomorrow and we'll do all of you I
promise
at the same time same coming place
Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon